Gary Vaynerchuk and this wildly handsome
man next to me is Zubin I'll let him
introduce himself welcome to another
episode of coughing Commerce subin's
been holding it down while I've been
running around the last couple episodes
and today we're together and we're
answering questions from the community
so if you want a question please use
hashtag coffee and commerce or coffee
commerce let's just do it that way
Dustin would look for the questions on
Twitter specifically we also see all the
comments here on the right side zhuben
why don't you give this weekend I'm
gonna open a glass of wine actually
while you give the weekly update of
things that you're seeing in e-commerce
world and let's get to the questions
let's do it yeah so as Gary mentioned
yes so as Gary mentioned really excited
with you guys today with Gods we thought
uh that's Dustin can you garrison can
you be Thanks okay we're good I left I'd
love to get a glass of wine you just
give everybody the Week in Review
yeah do yeah okay awesome
yeah so we can review I'm zooming
MonaVie the president of ATAR commerce
our focus is on sustainable growth for
our clients so a lot of what we look for
in terms of how we work how we think
etcetera isn't as much about looking
back at what's worked and what is kind
of like look back windows those are
important but the way we really focus
our efforts is on directional impact so
what we're looking for trends for our
clients trends that you guys should be
looking for as well one of the things
that's really interesting everybody's
talking about obviously ecommerce and
with what's happened with a covert
pandemic more people are ordering things
online and how is that going to be how
will that continue will it be
sustainable etc we're seeing some really
early indication of that directionally
then not only is it going to be
consistent it's also going to be growing
even further in certain sectors one of
the interesting things that one of our
clients shared with us today it's a
report from numerator and it's a really
interesting report and this is like
taking a look back at the last three
years not only just
three months but the fact there are
certain categories like liquid hand soap
and and body lotion shampoo conditioner
toothpaste all those CPG categories that
are blooming right now when enumerator
looked at them over the last three years
what they realized is that once somebody
buys online they tend to continue
purchasing online and not going back to
retail so what are the things I just
want to talk to you about is again the
fact that this isn't a fad this is like
the internet obviously this is just
gonna continue and the more you get
integrated online the more you look at
it as another Channel and kind of
integrated into your entire omni-channel
strategy the better off you are and then
one of the more encouraging things for
all of you that are starting new brands
out there and to really push hard at
this point where to go to the study that
indicated that 55% of Americans have
purchased online have purchase items
online from websites and retailers they
never heard about over the last three
months so it's like prime opportunity
right now to launch a brand get it out
there and put a ton of effort in terms
of building that brand community because
people are out there looking for new
brands to engage with I agree I was
listening to the far majority of that so
that was good let's get into questions I
mean everybody knows where I stand on
dummy Commerce like you know there's so
much opportunity obviously as we started
Bama Commerce that's why I bought
subin's company we're excited for you
all to be here let's answer some
questions all right Jonathan Atlas asks
what do you think will happen to the
retail space for my perspective retail
will stay
I think lease prices are gonna have to
come down I think that retailer is gonna
have to innovate to make it experience
based or access based over time but I
think the retail landscape will look
pretty similar in more than people
realize other than the economics will be
different so the stores will be less
busy we will need them to innovate for
that less traffic thus affecting the
owners of the real estate on lease
prices you'll see companies go out of
business new companies will emerge
paying new price points for their square
footage and I think you'll see
innovation around the reason for the
retail place to exist
more experiential more access thoughts
Zubin yeah because when a further proof
of Gary's ability to kind of force see
these things we talked about this months
ago in terms of retail and curbside
pickup and Gary was talking about how
that's really gonna morph the retail
industry business insider just came out
with a report recently that part of the
surge in terms of e-commerce revenue and
sales over the last few months is
attributable to curbside pickup and so
that's just growing again it's consumer
behavior right like yes retail is
shifting retail is changing those retail
stores are still going to be there but
just how you engage as a consumer with
them is gonna shift I think that's right
alright so Tamera Scarlett asks what are
your thoughts around the Walmart and
Shopify partnership your thoughts so I
think it's further proof that if you're
going to be selling online shop you've
got to take a look at Shopify right like
we've worked with all sorts of
e-commerce platforms the reason why we
leaned into Shopify five years ago was
because they offered the ability to sell
on multiple channels I mean you want to
be where your consumer is and then you
want to be able to manage it all in one
place
I think this Walmart Shopify partnership
is gonna not only be good for Shopify
but also for Walmart as well there's so
many of these online retailers like
black boxes you don't get any info out
of it now to be able to sell your
Shopify products directly on there so it
on Facebook etc now your omni-channel
yeah I think it's a good move for both
companies I think that you know Amazon
such a beast player in this game and you
know that partnership makes a lot of
sense
I have not dug in I'm a double click
into that partnership enough to give a
great answer but I think what Marc
Laurie is doing at Walmart the former
jet comm executive and obviously I'm a
huge fan of what Shopify is doing it's
one of the reasons I was so attracted to
subin's business because they were so
heavy in that ecosystem
this has fruitful ingredients it's kind
of like being now it depends on who's
gonna cook the partnership like I always
think about business and in the same way
I think about cooking a meal if you give
me the greatest ingredients in the world
the best foie gras the best seer should
the caviar the the best lettuce like I'm
not going to produce something so
remarkable you give a great chef
something with tier two in green
and she's gonna make something all time
and if God willing you give the best
chef the best ingredients now you get
into three star Michelin life and so I
like the ingredients of this deal I
don't have the knowledge of who's
cooking it but if that person and/or
team is extremely strong it has
incredible potential thanks Gary
my next question so I'll wait for the
next question one of the things there is
real real sergio 211 what do you think
about freelancer market places such as 5
or up work you know I have a different
point of view than a lot of creatives
honest a lot of creatives get mad at me
for liking these places because they
think it brings down the price and I'm
like that's nice it's called supply and
demand like if there's somebody that
wants tit like you make something and
sell something like you can't you can't
decide what the market wants or what the
market offers you can't people are
deploying their privilege on other
people who for $10 making a logo really
matters for them and so you know I'm a
fan of those marketplaces because I
think it's service is a need that's how
I see it yeah I just add to that to say
that you know this is happening all over
the place it's happening in music with
splice it's happening in multiple
industries and it's not a matter of for
the creatives it's a matter of
leveraging that as well and seeing why
where you can differentiate yourself
you're gonna charge ten times more
twenty times more what does it impact of
that creative and that's really where I
think you start to rethink the position
of creative and all this that's right
let's keep this move it I like this John
Marchetti asks how does this market
change ecommerce as a service versus
selling a traditional product zoom you
ever thought oh man I want to make I
don't find the full context of how he's
asking this yeah I don't either
hey John J see if you can get back in or
dust if you can get John on here I'm not
against that or we can get him on the
next come coffee and commerce so we'll
get him to physically ask the question
cuz I don't fully understand what he's
saying let's keep it going
so Raymond Wong what's your view on
PayPal's new policy on resale items and
protection for sellers I haven't seen it
but if you're saying that there's more
protection for the seller I'm very
excited I think that eBay needs to lean
into that I think I think all platforms
rightfully protected the buyer because
that's how you build it but I think
we're into that 2.0 3.0 that 201 301
course on here where you're seeing a lot
of people take advantage of the
protection that the buyer has and I do
think it's time for more protection for
the seller
I'm undereducated on what this is I
don't know if you're looking it up right
now
Zubin yeah yeah yeah I saw you typing
obviously you're just gonna headline
read so you're not gonna pull thought
but I definitely think as transactional
internet is happening in the sports card
world I'm seeing it a lot the markets
moving so fast that somebody buy
something with the anticipation of it
going up in a week it doesn't and then
they cancel the order and that's really
unfair and wrong morals for the merit of
the transaction yeah totally so just to
give everybody else some insight on this
again we got to do deeper dive into this
but basically the policy states that
they're excluding items intended for
resale from the buyer protection so
including single item transactions or
transactions that include multiple items
from reimbursement eligibility under
purchase protection program I say so
they're basically third faith the
incredible protections they have in
place in in the macro there they're
taking that away to see what that
probably feels like for a little bit
more Merit between the buyer and the
seller to not let because you almost now
see the you know at first in the early
internet the sellers were who you had to
protect against right now we're seeing a
world where we have to protect against
the buyers that's a really good that's
that's really interesting I'm excited to
dig in a little bit deeper awesome next
question
chef Chris Cho how can I sell kimchi
online shipping price is the same price
$10 as the kimchi by creating a $20
kimchi where it comes along with access
or a t-shirt or an empathy hat you have
to Crete when you sell low items low
priced items you either need to make the
item so awesome that people don't give a
[ __ ]
20 bucks for your kimchi instead of 10
or you need to create some sort of Club
access surprising the light when they
buy it from you when I say access maybe
you chef Chris are cooking the kimchi
with you know showing people like if
they buy from you they get to be on the
weekly you know taste along cook along
with you access it's almost like if I
out of $10 wine if empathy was 10 bucks
I would make it a $20 buy because it's
$10 for wine and $10 to be part of the
club where every Friday night for two
hours you get the drink wine and ask me
questions I think you need to do that
chef that's my idea so yeah you know the
only other thing I'd add to that is take
a look at gold belly so I grew up around
Chicago i order Gino's East for them all
the time and it costs a bit but you end
up ordering five at a time six at a time
so they don't sell them one at a time
sell it in a bundle do everything Gary
mention and then figure out why somebody
would want to buy from you and just
package it accordingly but the bundle
matters that was a good point and and
the lower hanging fruit I want it with a
little bit of like futuristic thinking I
think your thought a five pack is very
powerful yeah sweet next question Jeff
Hulk he asks thoughts on eBay handling
payments in-house and getting rid of
PayPal is that happening or is that like
his idea I think it's his idea some
someone someone else mentioned it to you
that's why I brought it up I'm guessing
while we go to the next question can you
google it or something something not on
my radar just as of yet okay that makes
sense I mean they're big enough they can
be their own bank and processing and you
know that's that's the thing well and
they're moving to adian so we've used
that before for some other clients of
whatnot it's just another processor yep
so they probably have alliance they
probably have better rates and a much
bigger exam and they have so much
leverage now yet make sense exactly and
then pate and then eBay will probably
provide you with the same little
protection that you were getting from
yeah yeah PayPal before all right shabam
Agarwal asks what problems and costs the
company's not much engaged in the
e-commerce sector it might face right
now and how would they move on so if
they're not in e-commerce right now what
problems and costs might they engage
once once they get into e-commerce
well hey the biggest problem is they
weren't in it and now the cats out of
the bag and so that's a huge [ __ ]
problem and they're gonna probably
overpay and be sloppy and try to move
one of the reasons I mean look Zubin you
know we've been working on the steel of
me buying a company for two years but
the timing could have been [ __ ]
better because like it's crazy how it
happened you know everybody needs you
now and like what I'm proud of is the
people that work with Bane or Commerce I
think are get thoughtful fast work but
fast a lot of time means sloppy and shoo
Bob I think the thing I'm most worried
about is that people are just gonna say
yes and pay for anything just because
they need to be an e-commerce and
they're gonna get ripped off kind of
like I did in 1997 with spacegate I'm
still trying to find you Alex from space
skate charged me $15,000 for a website
that I know he's built on Dreamweaver in
one day after I got educated two years
later what he actually did so my biggest
concern is people getting ripped off
second after that going through the
process of becoming e-commerce shipping
breaking [ __ ] you know like losing
tracking number like just real life
you're in a whole new business and
you're not used to it and it's gonna
take you six months to a year to get
used to it and that's gonna be sloppy
and costly and lead to some customers
who are unhappy awesome yep let's keep
it going
Christopher Stewart ass I know it's
intended as a platform for creatives ie
artists but what are your thoughts on
patreon as a platform to sell
educational how-to products yes all you
yes what do you think I mean what things
are intended to they evolved to Facebook
was intended to be for college students
it's just [ __ ] grandma's now you know
it was musically exactly you know
Instagram was intended for people to
take better photos and have filters on
them I think the the key thing you gotta
ask yourself is what are you educating
people on and how how much of it you
want to give away versus how much of it
do you want them to kind of engage with
you like Gary gives away pretty much all
of his knowledge all the time online and
and that's who he is and that's how he
operates now if you're gonna have like
some educational thing online you've got
to build that funnel right someone's
gonna want to be a patreon member like I
follow this Arsenal podcast our blog I'm
a patreon member to get deeper
information than what they offer for
free so that's all I would say like have
your own podcast have your own stuff and
go deeper in patreon yeah it's really
funny like I
thinking a lot during kovat about like
self-sufficient entrepreneurs a lot of
people out of jobs and I've I I think
I've subconsciously demonized paid
content because so many people doing it
we're kind of coming from it the wrong
way but that's like demonizing anything
you could you can you can handle a gun
the wrong way alcohol the wrong way so I
think I've got to make some content of
like yeah I I don't I think I would
crush if I had a $99 a month club where
for week four times a month I'd come on
for two hour I mean you know many people
if you would sign up for if I did a $99
you know one and a half hour Q&A small
group you know four times a month
you know just heavy access how many of
you would sign up just say yes or no in
the comments right now like you know I'm
not gonna do that but I think for a lot
of people that's a great business
because they can get 100 people and that
would be a big big deal you know and
that would really help them sustain and
once you build up credibility and you
would do it you know and so you know and
look there's a ton of answers of yes yes
yes and like you know you you get a
thousand people paying a hundred bucks
you got a you got a business suite all
right erh and the ives asks question i'm
starting a clothing brand and want tips
on how to stand on how to promote and
there's so many things that go into this
you know influencer marketing my man brh
you know like sending it to people that
you know DM 500 rappers athletes
musicians you know Olympians and just
try to you know unbelievable amount of
people you know from an influencer
standpoint I think tick tock is a huge
play right now I would make tick tock
concert like crazy around your brand I
think Facebook and Instagram ads are a
killer if you've got the dollars so
influencers tick tock and social media
ads really stand out but then you have
to be good at it it's like saying hey I
want to be a professional athlete okay
then go play you got to be good at it
and that's a lot of the punchline of
this this whole thing which is like
watch what I do not what I say I want
people to get better at it
totally and hit me up on Twitter I can
help you out of that yeah by the way
let's put up subin's
twitter handle one thing that was you
know one of things that was exciting to
me about you know buying subin's company
as we were going through and we
really became friendly through the
process I think we really connected and
it's come true I've just just to make
you blush Alameda Subin they've been a
great executive I love the way you're
interacting with all of Boehner ex your
leadership your humanity I just like you
a lot I was that I knew that you had
some ambition for more people to know
your expertise you've been in the space
and I was excited to like cosign you you
know it's kind of like you know Dre and
Snoop right like so I really highly
recommend if you care about e-commerce
to follow this man on Twitter he's doing
a really good job and in general
ecommerce you know web Smith others you
know there's so many people you know
Sally and Nick and Johnny like there's a
lot of people putting out good ecommerce
content on Twitter and I think you're at
the top of the game and everybody should
follow my man right now let's keep it
goin it appreciate you all right next
question what do we got Dustin sorry
still fishing through but I did check on
that PayPal thing yet it is gonna happen
that's make sense that make sense I mean
like you know will be interesting is
what what the friction if any like how
many people are annoyed because it's so
easy that the counselor connect them a
PayPal what what if any drop-off of
people who you know don't it'll be a
good how easy they're gonna make it for
me to switch to whatever their payment
system is subin's
humans Twitter is not private somebody
just said that so I think they might
have gotten it wrong this is right Zubin
way to have it yes I think my friend
whoever left that comment I think he
might have typed it in wrong so just go
to a question that I see right now from
Val the art what would be great strategy
to relaunch a brand on Amazon a Shopify
and a semi competitive niche and stay
top of the game look I think it's all
about marketing I think it's all about
communication if you're gonna be on
Shopify and Amazon or wherever you sell
it to me as commodity you'd like to sell
it somewhere better than it's bad if
you're in comp I mean this is why I
bought Stephens company if I can get you
to the site if the site's [ __ ]
you're not gonna convert as well in
there anything my ads are not working as
well and then I show you I've sent you a
bunch of people people don't like to
[ __ ] go through the shopping cart
with you so I'm thrilled with what Zubin
does for a living and I think that does
matter but
when you're gonna be on Amazon Amazon's
got that down and so what you need to be
great at is getting people there and
that's why I believe marketing social
media marketing specifically at this
moment podcast content acting like a
publisher influencer marketing tik-tok
this is all I talk about because it is
the punchline of every question and so
become a tremendous communicator in 2020
Lashon Trask is d2c that way to go with
regards to a peanut butter brand one
thing I just want to comment on with
that is something really interesting
that we're seeing with a lot of our
clients is you basically have a retail
before and yet online and we're kind of
promoting both of those spaces from them
but for them but what's interesting are
the instacart to the world the delivery
service providers so getting your peanut
butter brand into online obviously into
national retail it's big it's gonna take
some time to get there
but if you can grow it with d2c get your
following there and then start putting
it into local stores run some ads not
only adds to just go online and pie but
like instacart ads like start promoting
it there because when people are buying
peanut butter online at the local store
and they're getting instacart to deliver
it you want them to think of yours yeah
cool all right one can - asks will
websites ever be built via voice command
apps that's cool so what do you think
I think websites will definitely be used
via voice command apps and there I mean
Alexa's kind of leading the the force on
that end in terms of them being built I
have no idea yeah I think being voice
yeah I mean I think you're talking about
decades but I'd be surprised if they
didn't you know I'd be surprised before
I die if that's not how it's done I
really believe that I think 30 40 50 60
years around yeah there's something cool
there LinkedIn user is Aliexpress
ecommerce still a viable platform to
dropship from considering kovat now I'm
a little bit under educated on that so I
don't know if I can answer that
Zubin likewise I don't think I think the
supply chain is coming back and China
from what I'm hearing and so in terms of
like
using the dropship to Gary's point I'm
not as educated with it I would just say
when you're considering a dropship
business like seriously look into all of
the economics around it because there's
so many people they're like oh it's so
easy to sell on Amazon to satya then
they realize 30% gone 35% is gone up
from the top so just really understand
the business model regardless if it's
Aliexpress or anything else before you
just jump into it
cool
Ibrahim Cara Hundley asks Gary any tips
on growing the recruiting agency focus
on the fashion industry heavy content on
LinkedIn heavy I would make I would
probably post five to seven times
organic on LinkedIn a day you know about
why you why you're great at it what
you're you know companies I find good
talent if you're good talent call me
that leave a comment here DM e message
me let's get on the phone I would link
in content-heavy pod committed like a
poker hand Gary can you just give
everybody a quick overview from your
vantage point on LinkedIn Twitter
Instagram Facebook tick-tock
when where and how LinkedIn very good
b2b unbelievable organic reach similar
to Facebook 2011 similar to Instagram
2014 everybody here can post something
on LinkedIn in video audio written form
and get more people to see it than they
could ever imagine
very b2b focused but starting to become
more b2c focus I'm seeing people sell
wine and unbelievable amounts of like
clothes and peanut butter on LinkedIn
LinkedIn is Facebook 2012 Facebook the
best ad product you can target like
crazy
an incredible platform if you're trying
to reach 45 to 90 year olds with your
service Facebook groups are an
incredible thing to build where you can
get people into let's Facebook Instagram
is the one right now right it's the most
competitive it's the hardest to break
through but it is where the contemporary
18 to 45 year old culture is living
content is the variable it's hard to get
viral there it's the most competitive
and most important place and you
starting to feel like you're on the down
side of Instagram with a tux emergence
and a little fatigue but it's still a
beast that will be here for a long time
Twitter is an incredible platform for a
lot of people it should be the platform
you do the most listening Twitter search
is the best part of Twitter type in
dropshipping and see people talking in
the
get into the conversation it is a
cocktail party and you are you have
permission to join any convo that's
makes it a beast I'm a huge huge fan
tick-tock
make concept you want to make not what
you think you need to make on tick-tock
it's not about dancing it's not about
memes it's about you putting out what
you want to put out it's getting older
by the second 20 30 40 year-olds by the
second so I think tick-tock much like
Instagram much like Facebook will evolve
into something different than it
actually is that's my little speed round
that was kind of good we might team
Dustin we need to clip that that was a
good I know that's a that's a repost so
how the man I asked how would you scale
a one-man agency that has seven
dealership clients of 15 clients I would
hire I would I would hire I Lebon he'll
Ben I would absolutely give up some of
the profit to hire that's what I did
with Manor
I made no salary in the early days
that's how you scale you scale by not
taking money home you scale by taking
the 7 to 15 clients money and hiring
people it's hiring it's [ __ ] hiring
and it's firing when somebody doesn't
work cuz you can't waste the money and
productize helping as much as you can
like figure out what you're doing the
same for all of them
productize it normalizes you got better
margins and then when you're presenting
it to the other 2030 clients that you
want to get you've got a very clear
roadmap of where and and let's talk
about privatizing Zubin is a
technologist so he built things i
productized through systems and decks
that i repeat so i don't have to build
the course every time so and and then
having to people around me through it
osmosis i'm productizing through humans
that's awesome
let's get one more in before guns this
is fun this is a quick little 30 by the
way real quick in the comments how do
you like this for like 30 minutes boom
education like just curious by the way
I'm sure we're gonna turn this into
podcast podcast listeners thank you so
much for listening opens bring any value
just cure some people's thoughts in the
comments go ahead along Sinofsky asks
should a high-end skincare brand
what should a high-end skin bear brand
do now that other more popular major
brands aren't doing tick tock a hundred
percent
like seven organic pieces of content a
day on tick-tock DMing 100 here's the
formula seven organic pieces of content
on tick-tock 100 messages - tick-tock
influencers if they want samples and
then take that build a little quiz on
your site for your consumers that get
there so you can get a better sense of
who they are and then link them up with
the best products on your site for them
because at that point you're giving that
value you're getting insight from them
in the last 1 to 20 seconds Dustin type
it out Vayner commerce calm if you are a
director consumer brand if you're a
fortune 500 brand if your cousin has a
brand if your uncle works at a brand
please check out Vayner commerce calm we
are quietly and not so quietly building
the premier ecommerce agency with
incredible capabilities of consulting
building out websites just you know what
would you say that three or four things
that stand out at Vayner commerce that
really will see yeah what's the lowest
price point somebody can get at the
Vayner conversant what's cheapest [ __ ]
yourself anything yeah cheapest stuff
that we do is probably a 50k consulting
engagement so taking a brand and
building out an entire director consumer
strategy for them model and get out etc
great and I hope you enjoy this isn't me
you're amazing this is fun let's do this
third there was something here I love it
too bye everyone hit me up on Twitter
Gary Vee you can put that up there
Dustin in case they don't know I would
be shocked the Vaidya but but actually
not shocked Gary Vee but let me know
what you thought about this format in
this show cuz I'm gonna lose these
comments in a second when I kids click
this out and a hundred percent follow
Zubin follow Zubin on twitter as well it
is one especially if you're deep in this
world he's constantly talking about I
may talk about sports cards or the Jets
or something random or you know teak
grizzly new you know albums but you know
Zubin is consistently good on this so
we'll see you later thanks everybody bye
guys love you thank you Dustin